(jolly piano music)
- [Narrator] For Lego
enthusiast, Lucas Lettrick.
These aren't just toys
- [Lucas] This is the Lego
Creator Palace Cinema.
- [Narrator] They're serious
money-makers that he buys
and sells for profit.
The biggest online database
of collectible Lego sets
lists 1.2 billion worth of
the toys around the world.
- Lego Tron up here
we're in the 3 to $400 range.
This Lego Tie Fighter $200 a piece
is what these are selling.
The returns that I typically will see
is somewhere between 150
to 250% on a Lego set.
- [Narrator] Researchers say
Lettrick is one of tens of thousands
who concerned by the recent
volatility of stocks and bonds
are betting on the reliable returns
from this tiny but growing market.
- The average return on other collectibles
like wines or art, or automobiles, stamps,
are generally lower than Lego.
- [Narrator] This is niche markets,
a series that examines
small lesser known markets
that despite their size punched
well above their weight.
- There we go.
All right.
- And this one.
- [Narrator] Lettrick is an
insurance broker in Pennsylvania
and grew up playing with Lego.
- I kind of got outta Lego,
obviously, like most people do,
but then when I had my first boy Bruce,
we started building some Lego sets
and that's kinda what
rekindled the passion
and kinda the memories.
(playful music)
- [Narrator] This nostalgic
hobby with his children
turned into a lucrative
investment strategy
when Lettrick walked into a
Target about five years ago.
- I saw a Lego set, Lego
Ninjago, Destiny's Bounty
and I remember thinking
to myself at that time
I could literally just take this,
put it up online, sell
it, and double my money.
- [Narrator] Since then, he says
he's invested around $65,000
into building a collection of
Lego's most profitable sets.
The toys in this room typically cost
anywhere from $30 to over $500 at stores.
- So this is the 1989 batmobile.
This-
- For Lettrick,
the most important
factor in Lego investing
is knowing how to spot a winning set.
- You think Lego, you might think child,
but Lego is really geared a
lot of their sets nowadays
towards the adult collectors.
(ambient music)
- [Narrator] Larger sets like these
target the growing community
of adult fans of Lego
who call themselves AFOLs.
Rather than toys to play with,
they're usually looking for display pieces
and can afford these more expensive sets.
- You've got the informational plaque,
you've got kind of this stand to display
some of the iconic figures from the movie.
So it's a really beautiful set.
- [Narrator] To turn a
profit on these kits.
Lettrick, makes sure he
gets in at a low price
so he scours the market for
sets Lego is about to retire
or stop producing.
The official Lego store
and other retailers
usually sell them at a discount
to clear their stock,
sometimes as much as 40% off.
- This actually just
retired this past year
and I ended up picking
it up a couple of them
2 or 3 of them for $200 a piece.
Within just a short
period, 6 to 12 months,
this has already jumped up to 400 to $500
I believe is what this is selling on eBay.
(playful music)
- [Narrator] But in order
to make a larger profit
Lettrick says it takes patience
usually holding sets for 2
to 3 years before selling.
- Do you want a pristine
set that's sealed?
That's what a collector's looking for.
You wanna make sure you're
storing it on the right shelving.
You wanna make sure that
you're keeping humidity low.
- [Narrator] Lettrick says
he spends 2 to 5 hours a week
on his Lego investments,
and while it's more time-consuming
than other items in his portfolio,
he says his Lego sets have seen
the most stable growth this year.
- You don't get a lot of fluctuation
with the prices going way down, way up
like we're obviously seeing
right now with the stock market,
it's very volatile.
(ambient music)
- [Narrator] Economists say
that's because a Lego
market moves more slowly
than traditional investments.
- When some news come to the market
the stock market reacts very
quickly on the same day.
Lego is much less liquid market.
- [Narrator] Victoria Dobrynskaya
is an associate professor
at the Higher School of
Economics University in Moscow.
Since 2016, she's been specializing in
the Lego secondary or reselling market,
analyzing three decades of financial data
about the niche investment.
She says the law of supply and demand
helps Lego in the same
way as other collectibles
like luxury watches or fine wine.
- Once a bottle of wine
is open, open and drunk
so it disappears from the market, right?
The same with Lego.
- [Narrator] But what
gives Lego the advantage
over other collectibles, she
says, is it's affordability.
- Generally, other alternative investments
are more expensive
so the potential returns
are somehow lower.
I mean, if a Lego set appreciates by $5,
if initially its price was
$1, then it's a huge return.
- [Narrator] The Lego Group didn't respond
to requests for comment
about the growth of the resellers market
and its impact on the
company's product strategy.
- [Lucas] There are times
when you're gonna get
box damage like that.
- [Narrator] But high-end
Lego sets can come in
thousands of pieces
some of which may be
rare or newly designed.
So buyers expect the
cardboard boxes that hold them
to remain sealed and in
near-perfect condition.
- When you buy them distantly on eBay
or on some other platform,
you cannot check it.
So you need to be sure
that it is fully sealed,
because if a rare part is missing
that would be a very big problem.
(playful music)
- [Narrator] This niche
market is also at the mercy
of pop culture trends
where the franchises and
themes investors buy today
may not be relevant years down the road.
- That's just kinda part of
doing business and investment,
sometimes you win, sometimes
you lose a little bit,
but typically if you do it right
it all shakes out in the end.